il est plus de 23 heures devant la
station crémazie comme chaque soir le
métro s'apprête à fermer ses portes
l'activité pourtant ne va pas s'arrêter
dans les tunnels de la métropole aux
ateliers youville où l'on nettoie et
entretient les wagons d'autres véhicules
se met en marche avec à leur bord tout
ce qui est utile pour la maintenance du
métro
il est 1h30 du matin on quitte l'atelier
d'entretien aborde un locotracteur pour
allait s'engouffrer dans les tunnels du
métro de montréal
chaque nuit au total ce sont près de 300
personnes qui sont à pied d'oeuvre dès
la fermeture du métro dans l'un des 130
chantier actuellement tous vers moi
quand j'ai carrément arraché l'or
on se battra qu'elle-même le pcc il y
avait peut-être mais y'avait pas de
chantier y avait pas d'entrée c'est
qu'elle se manquer
non mais calculable de travailleurs ça
marche cette augmentation du nombre de
chantiers s'explique par une forte
hausse des investissements pour
l'entretien du métro entre 2017 et 2019
ces investissements sont passés 250 à
270 millions et pour 2022 une somme de
400 millions est déjà évoqué on vise à
accélérer dre d'une part on a un déficit
de métier d'investissements à récupérer
vous voyez des équipements des
installations qui datent déjà de 1960
sont d'origine une donne encore du bon
service mais il faut s'empresser
d'étagés a vaincu la fiabilité du métro
plus être affecté les travaux sont
multiples dans le métro de montréal
infiltrations d'eau consolidation d'un
mur usées soudure ou encore construction
d'une nouvelle passerelle comme ici au
métro mont royal où l'on veut mettre en
place deux ascenseurs on est en train du
père allemand de refaire une station par
nakheel est en exploitation
tout doit se faire en moins de quatre
heures chaque nuit avant l'arrivée du
premier métro prévue vers 5h30 un délai
qui comprend également le déplacement
des équipes et des matériaux
j'ai vraiment une course contre la
montre convient à tous les jours
contrairement au métro de new york par
exemple celui de montréal ne comprend
pas une double voies qui permettraient
de travailler tout en laissant circuler
les trains impossible donc d'ouvrir le
métro toute la nuit chaque fois qu'on se
prive de faire des travaux de nuit
il faut les faire à un autre moment donc
on prolonge la durée des travaux et qui
dit prolongation durée des travaux
d'augmentation des coûts est aussi un
impact sur la fiabilité car ce sont des
travaux urgents
ne comptez pas non plus sur une
ouverture prolongée du métro jusqu'à 2h
ou 3h du matin aucun projet de ce type
est envisagée par la stm ici romain chu
et radio canada montréal